i'm chris wallace i'm harris faulkner
i'm greg gutfeld and this is the fox
news rundown
friday october 8th 2021 i'm chris foster
president biden's economic agenda is
stuck with democrats in congress
disagreeing among themselves i mean
they're in real trouble and i think
there's every you know you if you had to
bet you would bet that democrats will
lose the house maybe not the senate but
the house if you can't pass your own
agenda with the majority slim as it is
you don't deserve to return the majority
of the house we speak with fox news
sunday host chris wallace
and lisa brady the pandemic is hitting
people in the pocketbook as supply chain
issues continue to fuel hotter inflation
the big question is just how long is it
going to run this hot and this high and
that's where the debate comes in
and i'm greg jarrett i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
president biden's honeymoon period as
it's known where new presidents are cut
more slack by the public ended around
the end of august more people were dying
of covet 19 the government of
afghanistan fell as american troops were
pulling out and more americans then than
not said they disapproved of the job the
president was doing overall since then
things have only gotten worse on that
front for him his approval rating is it
just 38 percent in the poll out this
week from quinnipiac university this
combination of a few things first of all
specific events like afghanistan like
the horror show
under the bridge in del rio texas with
15 000 haitians there chris wallace is
the host of fox news sunday which really
just gave the lie to the idea that we
have any control over the border the the
complete disarray in passing any part of
the domestic agenda last week but i
think it's more than that i think you
know it it this is a case where the
whole is greater than the sum of its
parts and the whole is just this
increasing sense in washington can
anybody here play the game you know is
anybody here competent and there's some
astonishing number where i think 55
of people polled
don't think
that that joe biden is and the biden
administration is competent right now
that that's pretty bad that's not a
policy issue that's a an issue of of
just an ability
to function and
i mean they desperately need something
to go right and uh you know whether it's
infrastructure whether it's a spending
bill whatever it is they just need
something to go right and it hasn't in a
long time yeah i mean what we were
supposed to get one of the selling
points of
of joe biden was that we were going to
get this boring competency that he'd
been around so long and knew how to
shake hands and and like you said play
the game but it's just it it's
everything's stuck nothing's happening
well and there was something else as we
talk about there are two cases of this
you know
with friends like this who needs enemies
john kerry
who's been known to say some dumb things
over the years like i was for it before
i was against it uh or maybe it was i
was against it before i was four
whichever it is
uh you know was was speaking in france
and said that that joe biden was
completely unaware that making this deal
with britain to sell australia nuclear
submarine technology was unaware that
this was going to take off the french
hello uh you know talk about chipping
away competence and then there was uh
terry mcauliffe in an event that was not
supposed to be
on the record talking about biden's
unpopularity and basically that you know
he's he's a weight not a help in getting
elected governor of virginia in in a
month so
you know people
this the joe biden doesn't have a lot of
support and a lot of help these days
i mean
at least uh when we spoke a week ago
there was this big sense of urgency
about a lot of stuff funding the federal
government avoiding debt default and and
you know passing infrastructure in the
democrats big spending plan at least now
there's some breathing room on all of it
yeah
and i i mean look it's better than the
government shutdown it's certainly
better than a government default which
we've never seen before so we don't even
know how terrible that would be
those are going to be kicked down the
road into december but you know there's
a limit to
how good i think people can feel about
that because they haven't been settled
they've just simply been
delayed for about six eight weeks and
meanwhile you know we're still in a
situation with the 1.2 trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure plan which is
nowhere in the house i mean they can't
pass it even though the democrats have a
majority and what originally was a three
and a half trillion dollar tax and spend
social bill which at this point they
don't even pretend that they're going to
need democratic republican support but
they can't even get an agreement among
democrats so
there's this sense
really right now i think in in so many
words what people both
supporters and
opponents of the biden white house are
feeling can anybody there play this game
it seems like there were there were
months of these bad faith
non-negotiations where the progressive
democrats said we're going to get this
and the center said we're going to get
this at least now they realize okay both
sides realize no we're not going to get
this and so at least now you can
negotiate from some place of
reality in some place of truth
well i agree with that and and you know
now we at least have a top line number
from the moderates which is nowhere near
three and a half trillion mansion keeps
talking about one and a half trillion
you know some of the democrats in the
house uh pramila jayapal who's the head
of the congressional progressive caucus
in the house is saying well no more like
2-8-2-9 no congresswoman you're not
going to get 2-8-9 you have nothing to
bargain with you don't have the votes so
and this is one of the things i don't
understand
let's say you've got two trillion
dollars in spending the left wing of the
democratic party both in the house and
the senate bernie sanders saying this
too is making it sound like you know
that that's a pittance that's
disgraceful two trillion dollars in
social spending would be one of the
biggest spending bills in history and
and the idea that you i don't know if i
had a choice between two trillion
dollars for my cause whatever that cause
was or zero because they have no
weight i mean the only way they have is
we can sabotage the bipartisan
infrastructure bill which incidentally
will create a lot of jobs that your
constituents that you're so concerned
about would like to have i mean i
understand bargaining but you've got to
be somewhat realistic it seems to me
that if you get to 2 trillion or 2.2
trillion or something like that the
democrats on the left wing of the party
ought to consider that a huge victory
and they ought to take it yeah i mean
one of their questions for manchin and
and kirsten cinema from arizona is okay
you can give us this top line number but
what do we cut
let's talk about what you're going to
take out of it is it the free community
college or the medicare expansion or
what is it some of that stuff is going
to be popular with the american people
too
well yeah but again
i mean and there are two arguments about
this and i went in this with a very
smart liberal congressman on sunday ro
khanna from california and there are two
arguments one is farmed fewer things but
fund them for longer in other words
instead of the whole pie
take 60 of the pie and really do it well
where the other idea is you know take
the whole pie and just shrink it so
instead of you're funding it for 10
years you're funding it for three or
four years and you just assume that it's
going to become so wedded
you know
ingrained in american society that you
won't be able to take it back
you know that's a legitimate argument
which which to do but but either way it
seems to me that you can figure out i
mean i remember covering ronald reagan
back in the 80s and he was in from you
know he was he was famous for saying uh
i'd rather have eighty percent of
something than a hundred percent of
nothing and the
you know the the left wing of the party
the squad
uh is in danger of getting 100 of
nothing i don't know that that's
something you want to run on in 2022 in
the midterm elections i mean they're in
real trouble and i think there's every
you know you if you had to bet you would
that the democrats will lose the house
maybe not the senate but the house
if you can't pass your own agenda with
the majority slim as it is
you don't deserve to return a majority
in the house
well i mean just a
sort of petty sounding thing about this
in party fighting is
senator cinema
got chased into a restroom by some
activists um the other day you know this
statement going around for democrats to
sign condemning that and bernie sanders
says nope not going to sign it unless
there's some language in there
criticizing her
i thought that was kind of cheap on his
part
look if you can't go into the ladies
room by yourself and you know not be
hectored by activists if the activists
want to wait outside the door and hector
you once you get out there there was no
violence there that's fine but you know
there ought to be some zone of privacy
and i think the ladies room is is it and
and i was actually surprised at joe
biden who said you know i thought it was
inappropriate but it's part of the
process when did that become part of the
process that people have followed into
you know into the bathroom and people
are lobbying them and taking videos and
things like that it's is it the end of
the world no but i think it's just part
of the coarsening of our political
discussion and
i i understand passion and i understand
people feeling very strongly one way or
the other but you know there's a line
somewhere and that certainly crossed it
i guess maybe speaking to that course
thing there's this new gallup poll that
trust in politicians is down you know as
usual but it's actually even lower what
i found more interesting is that trust
in other voters is down like you don't
trust your neighbors to do the right
thing and trust in media by the way uh
big media newspapers people like
you and to a certain extent me uh trust
in is down to seven percent in this
gallup poll i don't know if there's
anything to be done about any of it
wait wait why me but not you why you
only do a certain
crisis
they don't but they care about me less
they may trust me just as i don't know i
care about a lot of people say they just
hate you but in any case no look here's
what i think about this and i don't i
hate it it is that
it our
it's not just that you're conservative
or liberal republican or democrat it's
tribal you know it it
where you fit on the political spectrum
also
it says a lot about what part of the
country you live in whether you live in
the cities or the suburbs or rural your
view of faith the kinds of media you
consume and the kinds you don't and and
there was a wonderful statistic after
the 2020 election about the tremendous
majority that trump had in precincts or
counties that that had a
cracker barrel in it and conversely the
tremendous majority that that biden had
in the areas that had a starbucks and
and so what i'm saying is that there are
these tribes and you just
as you it's it and it's not just that
you root for your tribe you're actively
rooting and in fact apparently more
motivating than rooting for your tribe
is rooting against the other tribe
because you see them as such a threat
and i think that's where we are now in
our politics and our media in our
society and you know you see it in
school board meetings about the vaccine
and masks and
the views of mandates and stuff it is
just completely
colored our reality both on the right
and the left and i think it's very sad
because i as a result it's almost
impossible to have a good faith
conversation with somebody who disagrees
with you
well and that's the thing i mean
there used to be and maybe it's
rose-colored glasses but it seems to me
that there used to be
like you said good faith political
debate
where you were coming from a place of of
facts but then you know your opinion was
your opinion and you could shake hands
and move on and that seems to be sadly
not around
no i i i came to washington in 1978
there was still legislating going on and
they were still
uh whether it was on taxes or or
you know very
the big tax reform bill of reagan's in
86 uh social security the reform bill
that kicked the can down the road for
social security solvency for about two
or three decades uh immigration now you
can argue whether or not those were good
plans or not but they were bipartisan
plans where people came together people
accepted 60 of what they wanted
held their nose on the other 40 and made
some incremental progress that doesn't
happen anymore i mean it just doesn't
happen and and that is one of the
saddest things about what i've seen over
the last four decades in washington and
you know i don't blame one party more
than the other i think there's enough
blame to go around chris will always
host a fox news sunday thanks chris good
to talk to you chris
[Music]
this is greg jarrett with your fox news
commentary coming up
not only is pumpkin season in full swing
we now have just 78 days until christmas
a countdown that may be extra stressful
for many retailers and manufacturers
this year because the pandemic still
isn't over it's led to many ripple
effects on supply chains and log jams at
ports we've added another thousand
longshore members and they've been
showing up with record productivity but
jean soraka executive director of the
port of los angeles also told fox's
maria bartoromo this week there's still
a shortage of truckers and overall the
supply crunch isn't easing up yet and
there are a number of reasons for that
one is that we still have a labor crunch
fox business correspondent lydia who we
don't have enough people globally
working in our ports because they're
just asymmetrical coveted policies
happening in various regions of the
world
and um in some places like in china all
you need is one kobe case in some of the
ports and it shuts down the entire port
for those types of reasons we're seeing
it's very hard to get predictable
shipments out and into the water and
then when they do arrive at their
destinations say for example in la or
new york or down south in georgia
we have so many ships coming in at the
same time that they don't have enough
room to dock and we don't have enough
people to unload the ships and then we
also have a trucking shortage it's
estimated that we need something like 60
000 truck drivers in the united states
to meet the demand we don't have them so
that means it takes longer to get our
packages from the ships to their
destinations waiting at the other end
are retailers and their suppliers who
can't get everything they want and may
have to pay more for what they do get i
think right now is when we're starting
to hear from every vendor melissa
mccollum is a franchisee she owns a
learning express toys location in
birmingham alabama and by mid-september
had only received about one-quarter of
the holiday toys they're expecting by
then it should have been 50 percent and
the costs are rising like i get emails
daily saying not only are they
experiencing supply chain issues they're
going to have to raise prices because of
what it's costing them to get
containers from china and then it just
they're having to more or less air
freight everything over costing them a
lot of money so they're having to pass
on the cost to us
and which is raising the retail price of
a lot of items so things are that's
really starting to happen right now in
october september and october we're
getting a lot of price increasing from
our vendors have you also had to
try
to prep for the holiday season
sooner because of the you know the price
issues and having it be more difficult
just to get things into the store
exactly we're doing our most i mean our
best but we can't order
um early we started ordering in
june for a holiday season
and just um getting our hands on what we
can and our you know best seller items
that we know we generally sell every
year
core items and and just get as much as
we can and put them in storage um
off-site storage and just stocking up
the best we can now hoping to have
the best inventory we can when the
holiday shopping does start
as i know you're a franchisee but
in general terms a business like yours
that's smaller than like a home depot or
certainly then you know something like
an amazon um is it easier for you to
keep up with demand because you don't
need as many i think so yeah it
definitely does help that we're not
having to order a whole container of
items and we can order just
you know
24 pieces of something and not um
not having to order in such a big bulk
type ways as a big big box stores do but
i know at this point
what does all of this mean
for your business the combination of the
supply chain issues and the higher costs
with inflation
how concerned are you
going forward beyond you know this
holiday season
basically we've got to just try to
to get everything we can right now
and
i think as time goes on
into the holidays it's going to be
getting the best
prices i mean that you know our best
cost now getting stuff in now and will
also affect the
shopping season and that's why so many
stores are
telling customers to um shop early to
get the best prices the best
product
with the
worrying about the holiday sales
i just don't know because people haven't
gotten in that mode just yet
so we're
we're hoping to make it through the
holidays but like you said it's mainly
also worrying about the early spring
and getting product during that time as
well
one other thing um
just in terms of the pandemic not being
over unfortunately
have you
thought about having to pass more of the
cost onto the customer have you been
able to
not do that much at this point
because are you concerned you know about
people sticking with you if you will
yeah exactly we're that's a real
struggle for us
when we're getting when we're having to
pay more for the products it is causing
us to have to have to
raise the prices and you can only
you look at it you can only go so far
with that you know a and tweak and only
cost so much before people aren't gonna
are gonna buy it
so it makes us
aware also that they can go to amazon or
to um big box stores and pay less for
things and um that's not what
we want to do we don't want to be
pricier than everyone else
we do want
people to shop with us but at some point
if if
they keep raising their prices on us and
and we also get a lot of surcharges
added on as well
for um shipping costs and shipping
reasons then you almost have to charge
more to make money and that brings us
back to fox businesses lidia who and
inflation prices rising for a wide
variety of goods not just gas and milk
as those supply chain issues push up
production and delivery costs you won't
find anybody that says that we have
inflation that's running away and out of
control certainly people are very
cautious to say this is not what
happened during the 1970s
um but you really can't deny that
inflation is here and that americans are
feeling it in their pocketbook i mean
the latest estimate is that inflation is
up 5.3 percent
over last year which means that across
the board for all the types of consumer
products that you and i and everyone
else need from food to electronics
appliances clothing
it's costing on average about five point
three percent more than it did just a
year ago when usually the year-over-year
rate is right around two percent so it's
higher and hotter than what it usually
is
the big question is just how long is it
going to run this hot and this high and
that's where the debate comes in you
know the fed the federal reserve is
has has insisted that it's transitory
which means that it's temporary and it's
driven by the pandemic
but there's a debate and a lot of
concern that that's not true that we've
had a lot of free cash injected into the
system which means we have a lot of
money
chasing fewer products
fewer products being made available
because of supply chain issues and
that's where we are seeing prices go up
more money chasing fewer goods and how
long is that going to last when it comes
to the labor crunch the worker shortage
it doesn't seem as though there's a big
rush back to the labor market for people
who haven't gone back yet for a variety
of reasons is there any evidence that
the millions of people who still haven't
come back
will anytime soon we're still waiting
for an indication that more people are
being hired and placed in job openings
the last report we got from
august was a big mega
miss in terms of what was expected you
know we were expecting somewhere in the
neighborhood of like 728 000 jobs having
been added for the month of august and
it came in under 300 000 well under 300
000
and it was a big surprise and the
question was
you know why is this driven by the delta
variant is this driven by stimulus
benefits the the extended unemployment
the boosted unemployment stimulus
benefits still being distributed
a lot of those
answers to those questions hopefully
will be hinted at when we get the next
jobs report which comes out on friday
morning
we're going to be looking to see how
many people were hired for the month of
september because that's going to
capture the end
of those
stimulus benefits the boosted
unemployment benefits
the hope is that you'll see more people
having returned to the job market with
that having been said though there are
other indications that people are
reluctant to return to the office
there's more of an increased expectation
that work be work from home or hybrid
there's an expectation that companies
now be more flexible
and people are increasingly surveys show
um becoming more skeptical about
returning to a job that they possibly
had before or during the pandemic it is
a workers market out there hiring is
happening left right and center
companies are competing for the same
pool of workers trying to make their
jobs look attractive
and you know workers are negotiating
that so
they're using that to their advantage
asking for more money for more flexible
benefits and it's just trying to find
the match the employees
the workers finding the jobs that
they're willing to go back to and so far
we're just not seeing that yet fox
business correspondent lydia who thank
you very much for your time
thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com now some good news
with tanya j powers
[Music]
fox news is marking its 25th anniversary
celebrating its october 1996 launch
special coverage is planned starting on
sunday night with the one-hour fox news
channel 25 years it will feature
interviews and behind the scenes footage
and showcase the evolution of the
channel from the perspective of some of
its most prominent personalities like
brett bear jennifer griffin and steve
ducey there will also be short videos
commemorating the anniversary from
celebrities and other guests including
former president george w bush and nfl
legend brett favre
fox news channel 25 years airs sunday
night at 10 o'clock eastern on fox
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind no one should be
physically attacked or threatened with
bodily harm that is a given
but attorney general merrick garland is
exploiting this fundamental doctrine as
a pretext to coerce and frighten parents
whose only supposed crime is seeking to
improve their children's education
garland intends to silence mothers and
fathers who vigorously oppose their
students being
indoctrinated with critical race theory
and other socialist or marxist dogma
to accomplish it garland plans to
weaponize the immense powers of the fbi
and the department of justice to bully
parents into submission
under the guise of combating what he
refers to as intimidation
he is exerting more intimidation with
superior force he aspires to criminalize
contentiousness
these are menacing and unconscionable
tactics by him designed to abolish free
speech rights under the threat of
federal investigation arrest and
prosecution in essence the attorney
general has ordered you to shut up or
else
the genesis of garland's dictate can be
found in a recent letter sent to
president joe biden from the national
school boards association
the leftist group demands that the doj
use domestic terrorism laws against
parents who attend school board meetings
to vocalize their opposition to the
inclusion of critical race theory within
classroom instruction as well as mask
mandates for children
right on cue garland capitulated by
threatening to investigate and prosecute
parents who dare to protest
against the teaching of what they regard
as woke propaganda and radical
brainwashing in classrooms
in his order garland embarrassingly
misstates constitutional law he claims
that the first amendment does not
protect quote efforts to intimidate
individuals based on their views
what
where is that written in the myriad of
u.s supreme court decisions involving
free speech
even more confounding was the attorney
general's assertion that he has some
imagined jurisdiction over local school
boards and any potential crimes arising
from their public meetings
those are issues solely within the
province of local police
there is no valid federal authority over
such matters
the idea that irate mothers and fathers
should be equated with domestic
terrorists is repugnant
garland's threat to punish parents for
their sometimes vituperative views is an
egregious abuse of power
this is nothing more than a corrupt
attempt by the attorney general to
target political opposition he wants to
repress speech and discourage any
resistance
if you're not careful with the words you
choose they may come banging at your
door sooner than you think and that is
precisely what biden and garland want to
chill free speech and extinguish any
dissent
i'm greg jarrett
fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio on the fox news app download
it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes